Speaker 1: All right. You knew it would
happen. You knew that the conspiracy theories
would explode thanks to this raid at Mar a Lago
that took place of the failed former president.
And one of those conspiracy theories that is now
spreading like wildfire is that the FBI planted
evidence against Donald Trump now. Is there any
reason to believe the FBI planted evidence at
Mar a Lago against Donald Trump? No. Is there any
specific claim being made about what was planted?
No. Do we have any reason to believe that the FBI
planted evidence against Donald Trump? No. But
that doesn't stop them on the right from saying
it. The new Trump right wing talking point is that
evidence was planted. This suggests the reality
is almost certainly that there was no evidence
planted and whatever was found at Mar a Lago is
probably not very good for Donald Trump. Let's
look at some examples. Here is Jesse WATTERS, an
absolutely horrible person on Fox News. He says
the FBI is probably planting evidence and he goes
even further and says they probably doctored the
evidence to get the warrant in the first place.
Speaker 3: How horrible is that? They could have
easily negotiated the return of documents like
that without guns and warrants. What the FBI is
probably doing is planning evidence, which is what
they did during the Russia hoax. We also have a
hunch they doctored evidence to get the warrant.
Speaker 1: Well, a hunch that sounds like it's
Jesse WATTERS feeling. What's that thing that
those right wingers always say something like
the facts don't care about your feelings. And
there's a lot of feelings coming from Jesse
WATTERS, but very few facts. Then Charlie Kirk
interviewed Newt Gingrich. That's a match made
in heaven. And again, make the suggestion that
the FBI planted evidence at Mar a Lago. Do they
have any justification for that claim? Absolutely
none whatsoever. But they're all on the same page,
at least as far as the talking points go.
Speaker 3: You really are now seeing the ugly face
of a tyranny. And the left is so desperate,
so frightened. And you're watching Trump win
again. Apparently, the last four votes came in and
his candidate beat another of the people who
voted to impeach him. So he's now I think
I think he's now defeated seven of the ten people
with a couple of voted to impeach. Right, Joe?
Well, in one case, even Kevin McCarthy talked him
out of challenging Valadao because we wouldn't
keep the seat. And I think Trump wisely
said, okay, I'm going to give him a pass.
The next big test, of course, will be Liz Cheney,
who I suspect will lose by 20 or 30 points.
Yes. And she's part of this. I mean, she is part
of the effort to turn the system into a basically
a tyrannical, anti-conservative, anti
Republican constant violation of the law,
which is what the January six coming.
Speaker 1: Now, none of that's
true. But here's the key moment.
Speaker 3: You have a fake committee
being covered by the fake news with a
fake FBI, which, by the way, you'll notice
they didn't allow anybody on
the Trump side in Tamara Lago.
So we have no idea whether or not they planted
evidence. Yes, that's exactly right. And and Newt,
I have a couple of thoughts. Number one.
Speaker 1: They have no idea whether they
planted evidence. Another way to say the same
thing is we have absolutely no proof that they
planted evidence. We have absolutely no empirical
basis for claiming that they planted evidence.
And what we do know is that everything
about the execution of the search warrant
was handled, as it always is, arguably with even
more discretion because of the sensitivity of the
individual involved. One other example here.
This is Trump lawyer Olina Haba. I don't know
where all these lawyers come from. There's so
many Trump lawyers. This is Trump lawyer Olena
Haba. She goes on Fox News and she also floats
the idea that the FBI planted evidence. There
is no evidence that there was planted evidence.
Speaker 3: Is a joke. This is a memento. And quite
honestly, I'm concerned that they may have
planted something. You know, at this point,
who knows? I don't trust the government. And
that's a very frightening thing. As an American,
if I didn't want to be an American and go to a
nut, this is Third World stuff. We've heard it.
This is Cuba. This is this is not our country.
Speaker 1: Now, you know, the truth is, one of
the problems with some of the countries they
love to talk about is third world countries or
banana republics or whatever term they love
to use. One of the problems is that there is
no accountability for people in positions of power
and privilege. It distinguishes us if indeed there
are consequences to people in positions of power
and privilege from those very countries. It makes
us different because in those countries you don't
see accountability. Donald Trump also, by the way,
floating this idea that evidence was planted.
He went on his platform, truth, social,
and he said, quote, The FBI and others from
the federal government would not let anyone,
including my lawyers, be anywhere near the
areas that were rummaged and otherwise looked at
during the raid on Mar a Lago. Everyone was
asked to leave the premises. They wanted to be
left alone without any witnesses to see what they
were doing, taking or hopefully not planting. Why
did they strongly insist on having nobody watching
them, everybody out? Obama and Clinton were never
raided despite big disputes, folks. Not a shred
of evidence presented that anything was planted.
They will attack the FBI. They're already doing
it. Even though the FBI director was appointed
by Donald Trump. And Trump gushed about how great
his credentials and honesty and everything was.
They will attack the judge who signed the search
warrant. I'm already seeing that this morning.
They will attack the DOJ as a tool
of Democratic President Joe Biden,
even though the evidence is the White
House wasn't even informed about this raid.
They will attack Merrick Garland himself, which
are all they're already doing. They will attack
Joe Biden, which they're already doing. And they
will talk about Hillary Clinton and Benghazi.
They will talk about Hunter Biden's laptop.
They will talk about Obama. I don't even
know why they're talking about Obama. I don't
understand why you would raid Obama. None of
it makes any sense. And they are doing every
single one of those things. Now, later on,
we're going to look at a serious case of brain
worms. The new thing is increasingly the next
level. Conspiracy theory, above and beyond
evidence was planted is this is the beginning of
a plot to assassinate Donald Trump. Now, if your
plan is to assassinate Trump, I don't know why you
need to serve a search warrant first. I don't know
why you need to go through the trouble of legally
obtaining the search warrant. If your plan is to
assassinate Trump, it doesn't pass the sniff test,
but that has never mattered to them. So
we will look at that a little bit later.
If you're curious about some of these clips that
we played during the segment, you can find all
of them on our Instagram at David Pakman show.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman as well.